ja also herzlich willkommen zu unserem
spezial blog wie anlässlich des
tausendsten argumenten von viera cast
und das wollen wir heute etwas zu gehen
durch ein ganz kleines video live
gesendet um smartphone ist es nämlich
auch das ist möglich ist wenn man 1000
abonnenten hat in der definition und wir
sind hier also im sekretariat in unserem
kleinen studio und hier sehen wir jetzt
unser berühmtes egal wo vor immer die
ganzen videos stattgefunden haben und
dienstgeber mal so ein bisschen mehr
wild und zum toaster kommt man mit einer
zelle denn ist es hier sehen wir also
schon die ganzen funktionen
das ist jetzt unser zentrum der
aktivitäten als wir sehen wir wir haben
entwickelt weiterentwickelt von
allerersten sendung die immer nur so 15
minuten gedauert haben experten
interviews mit einer semi hatten wir
hier neuerdings sitze livestreams eine
ganz neue funktion und die podcast laut
kanalnetz auch hier alles gerät mit der
schönen kamera hier zudem zu beginn
genauer was wir alles gemacht haben
darüber gibt es auch noch eine neue
familie in ein paar tagen genau und wir
haben jetzt eine andere sony alpha 6000
wir haben jetzt nämlich zwei davon wir
gehen wir noch ein bisschen in sich
hinein da wirklich hin zu ganzen herzen
ein eleganter verstauen als instanz
stative und sofort und diskussion so zu
sorgen ja wir haben schon auch auf
unsere türe aber auch schon so ein
bisschen was vermehrt nämlich hier 1000
menschen das handels gefeiert auch eine
türe und ansonsten jetzt glaube ich
nicht mehr viel zusammen
er sagt mir wir sagen danke danke dafür
dass hier so teuer lebenszeit und uns
weiterhin unterstützt mit vielen live
sky news und mit vielen kommentaren
hoffentlich auch da sind auch sehr froh
wenn deine kommentare die vorfreude da
und ich vergesse alles was in der
zukunft kommen wie zum beispiel auch der
philipp gerade mal so philipp weiter
wir sind jetzt alle leitungen und dann
ja das ist es eigentlich von uns für
seite kommt nochmal alle zu mir sagen
tschüss und bis demnächst wieder dabei